sapete che c'è
non mi sgolo per fa la intro perché ho
una certa età poi perdo il fiato non so
più spaventarmi negli horror perché
faccio tutto all'inizio e allora bella
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono felice oggi siamo tornati sul
lech view kevin non so se vi ricordate
io sì purtroppo perché non ho mai vinto
a questo gioco come se ci fosse un gioco
in cui link
vorrei ragazzi lakeview kevin è un gioco
dove tu entri in una c'è questo cinema
entra in una porta e come se ci fosse un
film in realtà tu vivi dentro il film e
ci sono dei mostri succedono cose strane
il suo gioco non ho mai capito
entriamo ho provato le ultime due mappe
che dovrebbero essere ok questo è un po
diversa dalle altre
a jado schivare i tipi ok se mi
rappresenta niente faccio schifo sta
roba perché non era non è così lakeview
kevin non so cosa sia successo
ah ecco a stavo giocando e va bene così
h l'high pensa un gioco perché faccio
schifo giocato mi sembra ovvio e giusto
lo giustifichiamo comunque in ogni mappa
di lucky luke evince un cattivo
deduco che sia questo pelato immagino
poi non ne son sicuro però vediamo io
sono questa
salve sono una ragazza va bene e sono
solo questa
a noi ci sono più persone ma che figata
[Musica]
ok quindi siamo sempre in quattro si
gioca sempre in quattro poi
intercambiare i personaggi
l'ambientazione è diversissima da tutti
gli altri da tutte altre mappe di
reclute vin è veramente via eccolo ci
sono misura riunito con un compagno
ok queste invece di eh beh non sembra
nichelino alla porta è chiusa mi sono
chiuso dentro casa dove non è male in
questo gioco non è male chiusasi in casa
secondarie a pian di sopra ancora
certamente in teoria man mano che giochi
succede qualcosa adesso non so cosa
dovrebbe succedere questa roba
sto facendo
cosa non è vero c'è la tavola misa e no
non si gioca da sola da tavola ouija si
gioca in 50mila tutti e quattro gli devo
portare a casa mia allora speck e arrivo
a porta non so quale sia a casa mia
proviamo vede questa è questa
mi sa di no alberto causa ragazzi via
veloci nasconditi non toglie attive city
nasconditi porca vacca mie schiattato un
personaggio
ok bene nelle altre mappe non era così
in teoria il mostro arriva da lontano
piano no quasi teletrasporta mi fa
piacere un armadio denudati che cosa me
ne frega nascondetevi usateli armani per
come pure perché gioco stupido
qual è l'utilità di denudarsi puoi
aprire la porta per favore di non
riuscire a comandare il mio amico morto
ok c'è una porta quindi puoi morire e
risorgere wow
cioè si spera si possa risolvere lo so
dove che sono quanto tetro so già cosa
vuoi tu chi sei
chi ti conosce un limbo
tutto a posto stavo solo controllando
degli iscritti al canale sono qui va
bene io non ho capito questo devo fare
dove devo andare però c'è il triciclo
via raccomandare io vorrei capire dove
sta allora tu stai qui pene che vorrei
nascondere tutti i miei personaggi
invece questa se metà fa morta sul letto
quest'estate a quella la fionda con la
fionda posso colpire le cose non male
c'è la poule a salve sono risorto io e
ora sono sul triciclo so che non ci
credi ma è così comunque lo scopo del
gioco è ammazzare il tipo che avete
visto prima però non so quando compare
non so come compare poi compare pressi
select to view info non certo fosse
chiuso l'xbox prove ma i parenti leave
the 8 pm si va beh la chiave è nella
cassetta della posta
e questa di parenti i suoi genitori sono
dati alle 8 quindi posso aprire la
parola la casa con le chiavi nella
cassetta della posta
that's it che fenomeno si può aprire hai
visto che amico che c'hai gag e che
scopre le cose mango sherlock holmes e
adesso posso uscire o le abbiamo
liberato tutti e quattro grazie a dio
quali riuniamo tutti e andiamo a farsi
ranger tings si spera allora io sono già
finito nel sottosopra tocca a voi
in teoria ma è il suo mostro compare a
caso solo che non capisco quando
dovrebbe arrivare il mostro e come
combatterlo perché non ci sono armi qua
questa è la casa del mostro si trova qua
non posso entrare perché chiusa devo
trovare il modo per aprire questa la
chiave nel bidone ci deve essere una
chiave nascosta ragazzi a cercarla tanto
sono già morto una volta non posso maria
di nuovo
via via via via via via veloce porca
vacca cioè una maledizione questo tizio
tu mi ha via via trento riciclo via non
sarò io uil in questo strange thing
sbagliato dire ragazze corre via via via
via veloci veloci non possa muoversi ce4
e mame mor e sempre lui dentro veloci
porca vacca morta generata è morto il
mio amico e basta però aridaje pazzini
eccoci ma non era così l'uscita
nell'aldilà di prima però avete un'ascia
la prendo aia aiuto
cosa succede
[Musica]
si sta rompendo la porta al demonio ce
l'ho fatta e sono fatti sono vivo ok ha
quindi se tu completi su mini gioco può
rinascere credo tanto il mio triciclo
noto gliene sono filate mi sembra di
aver capito che il mostro si nasconde in
una parte del della zona te lo becchi to
stavolta scherzavano lo becco io uscite
e prendi un arma fa qualcosa
proviamo a colpirlo su tizio
all'edizione perché non riesco a
colpirlo porco demonio e ovunque la pula
c'è ma guardalo
ma non lo vedete voi che poliziotti
siete c'è una zucca speck e proprio lato
demonio gli arancioni
ma dov'è andato eccolo eccolo vieni qua
si sa che sto parlando
grazie ma non lo pensa lo pensa perché
la festa la chiave lo trovano a chiave
ma come no ho perso la chiave porca
vacca come ho fatto che sia un mattone
ovvero bellissima groppone chiare ho
capito
forse devo usare la chiave in tempo per
halo colpisco a noi che si è aperta la
porta alla è la chiave era fittizia
apriva la porta automaticamente perfetto
che figo ok allora ho colpito il tipo si
è aperta questa casa il primo è
racchiusa andiamo ad esplorare per il
bene della mia curiosità ci siamo questa
è diventata bianca tra l'altro a no
forse è una sequenza che penso di dover
mettere tutti e quattro i tipi
innanzitutto gli avevo radunati il che
non è male perché gli altri non vanno
scusa se quella roba di una siringa tu
stai qua così almeno avrei sbloccato
qualcosa non so cosa ma vediamo il sì lo
facciamo un'altra volta via via via via
veloce riciclo pedala
anzi è questo la fionda eccolo sta
colpendo il mattone e non lo colpisco ai
ha programmato la prima torre il mattone
il mattone non è non è più di mattone
corrente para rugby ora cavalca
quaterback ma che mira perrotta che ciò
bulava guardalo c'è un coltello e va a
fan culo vale ragazzi non so come
continuarla perché la vera mente la
parte più strana nel xvi kevin cela la
mappa bisogna dire che se ben e
veramente difficile prefissi mo cioè nel
senso è diversa da tutte le altre
veramente figo
allora sei proprio brutto sono nuda non
puoi uccidermi ecco invece potevi farlo
e va bene è molto strano solo lakeview
kevin ma vi assicuro che pure gli altri
erano peggio ragazzi io non so come
concluderla perché non ha una fine
sembra però sembra aver ucciso un killer
ma non è così i ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto
fatemi sapere se sapete come continua
perché non ho idea però è stato
fighissimo veramente figo come al solito
ragazzi seguito vi è piaciuto lasciato
un commento è un mi piace anche la
pagine istagram che trovate in
descrizione e noi ci chiediamo come
sempre ad un prossimo vedo perché non
sono più capaci a tenere il telecomando
in mano perché è bene ragazzi
[Musica]